developing a character we keep hearing
about that there's classes on that what
does this mean
and how can someone develop a character
whether it's someone that's a walking in
an agenda or yeah well developing a
character I've got a couple of tools
that I use in class one of them has to
do with developing a skill okay when you
watch a character actually develop a
skill whether it's a physical skill of
fighting or whether it's an emotional
skill of learning how to connect with
somebody you're watching that character
develop and you're watching it an
experience is happening in front of us a
scene is happening an event is happening
we can see the development so that's one
way to develop a character what skill
physically or emotionally are they
developing another way to develop a
character is to think what are their
ongoing patterns or rules that we always
see them do and then do they break that
rule when they break that rule where
they shy away from their pattern they're
developing
you